this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the streaming platform built by
all your favorite youtubers
when you sign up for curiositystream at
the link below
[Music]
the world is full of valuable resources
some are valuable because they produce
energy
others because our ancestors found them
a convenient medium of exchange
but there's one resource that stands
above the rest one that has allowed the
continued existence of life on earth
water earth is known as the blue planet
over seventy percent of the earth's
surface is covered in water
but most of it is very salty humans
require fresh water
which represents only three percent of
the planet's total amount
of that three percent two-thirds are
frozen in ice caps and glaciers
leaving just one percent of the water on
earth fit and available for human
consumption
if that sounds like a disaster waiting
to happen it's because it is
climate change and growing water
consumption are rapidly depleting this
vital resource
and that's leading to global tension in
this episode we're going to discuss the
consequences of our shrinking water
supply
and what we should expect in the coming
decades let's start with some basic
facts
human civilization is heavily dependent
on water there's a reason
90 of human populations can be found
within 10 kilometers of a body of fresh
water
over the years some cities have misused
their water supply or failed to consider
its importance
leading to problems down the line mexico
city is one notable example
initially constructed by the aztecs
mexico city was once located on a large
lake
over the years the spanish drained the
lake to make room for more buildings
and today the city is home to over 20
million people and an acute water crisis
cape town south africa is another
striking example beginning in early 2017
the city started to experience a severe
water shortage and over the following
year
they became the first major metropolitan
area to begin a countdown to day zero
the day they would completely run out of
water and shut off the taps
this was quite a wake-up call to the
people of cape town and between strict
government rationing of water use and an
impressive response by the people
the city was able to push back day zero
several times
and eventually stop the countdown
altogether but these emergency measures
will not be enough going forward
more and more cities are facing water
shortages and the brunt of the suffering
disproportionately affects poor people
those who are already living
precariously water insecurity and
inequality are only getting worse
according to an assessment by the un a
full two-thirds of the world will live
in water-scarce regions by 2025
which could displace as many as 700
million people
and by 2040 most of the world won't have
enough water to meet demand year round
we can get by without most resources but
we cannot live without water
a human being can only survive three or
four days without water
it's non-negotiable when a region
experiences a water shortage
it starts a domino effect that can have
disastrous consequences
water scarcity leads to food insecurity
as crops die and farmers can't irrigate
their fields
critical systems begin to fail sparking
violence either internal between members
of the affected population
or external by their government to
secure more water from contested sources
these are usually small scale conflicts
and often don't involve the use of
military force
fighting over water is not unheard of
but so far
there have been fewer than 30 instances
of armed conflict over this precious
resource
this number will increase dramatically
in the coming years
so what factors are causing these
problems and can we avoid them
a big part of the problem is climate
change as global average temperature
rises
regional weather can become erratic and
unpredictable we are seeing more
droughts
more wildfires hotter temperatures and
less precipitation
often in already critically dry regions
as these weather trends continue
water reserves will dry up and regions
without the means to secure more water
will face a serious problem
we all need to drink water to survive
but we also need to allocate water to
produce food
farming especially less advanced methods
uses a tremendous amount of water
growing necessary region appropriate
crops is one thing
but we humans also have a tendency to
demand food that is incredibly water
inefficient
the king of these inefficient foods is
beef for each kilogram of beef purchased
by the consumer
we spend 15 400 liters of water
per cow that's 2.7 million liters
more water than you'd find in an olympic
swimming pool one comparatively easy way
to conserve water would be to limit the
amount of beef we produce
we in the imperial core have become
accustomed to being able to buy whatever
food we want whenever we want it
this comes with serious consequences
including the use of slave labor in
developing countries
and highly inefficient farming methods
to produce crops we normally wouldn't be
able to get in certain seasons
considering the average american's
carbon footprint and level of
consumption
far exceeds the global average we need
to be willing to make some sacrifices to
help mitigate both climate change and
stress on the dwindling water supply
the final factor that influences the
availability of water is allocation of
the handful of major freshwater sources
around the world
there exist a number of critical rivers
that provide water for huge numbers of
people and vast expanses of farmland
and more and more often the people
towards the end of the chain
aren't getting enough the five big
locations for control of water are the
ganges
the nile the tigris and euphrates the
indus and the colorado river
i recently worked on a documentary about
the state of the colorado river
and the problems we face here in the u.s
are pretty alarming
the colorado river provides water for
seven states many large cities
including los angeles and las vegas five
and a half million acres of farmland
and over 40 million people it's
currently in its 20th year of drought
there is more water leaving critical
reservoirs like lake mead and lake
powell
than there is flowing in lake mead
currently sits at 39
capacity and lake powell at 36 percent
if the drought continues and at this
point people are having to seriously
consider whether this is simply the new
normal
a large portion of the us will run out
of their reliable water supply in a
matter of years
states like arizona are having to start
prepping for their own day zero
countdowns
and tension between states and between
urban areas and agricultural areas is
becoming more severe
each state wants to ensure they get
their allotted water and that's becoming
more and more difficult
fighting between municipal water
providers and farmers is constant
the urban areas saying they use water
more efficiently and provide water to a
far greater number of people
while agricultural areas claim their
farmland as their birthright
and assert that they're providing a
valuable service to the country by
producing their crops
while farming is critical we do produce
a lot of crops in desert regions to
accommodate spoiled americans wanting
certain foods all throughout the year
which requires an enormous amount of
water water rights are an incredibly
complex and fraught topic
but i suspect american farming practices
will eventually have to change
but whether in the u.s or around any of
the other key rivers
many of the disputes over water
ownership stem from overuse of rivers
poor logistical planning and the
construction of dams or diversions
which downriver populations feel often
rightly are preventing them from getting
the water they need
this is especially common along the nile
where egypt often doesn't receive enough
water by the time the nile has passed
through the nine nations further
upstream
regardless of where in the world these
tensions arise they all present a
potential flashpoint for conflict
especially in regions where a water
source is shared by nations with less
than friendly relations
i'm sure many of you heard the vice
president's recent statement about water
and here's the other thing because i
also you know i'm in a lot of meetings
on foreign policy
you know for years and generations wars
have been fought over oil
in a short matter of time they will be
fought over water
while it is striking to hear a
politician admit that current wars are
fought over
oil and not to spread freedom and
democracy like they so often claim
this is actually a 1995 quote by a
former world bank vice president
we've known for years that our water
supply would become a point of
contention in the next few decades
and we've done very little to mitigate
the problem in fact
just like with climate change those in
power have tried to find ways to
monetize the suffering of others
the us is the most powerful country in
the world by far
that fact has completely gone to our
heads and because of this
american leadership feels we have the
right to invade other nations for
literally any reason
or no reason at all when we figured out
we'd need more oil to maintain our
dominance
the u.s invaded countries with large
amounts of oil the
same will happen with water we'll occupy
countries where water conflict is
starting to pop
up we'll claim we're there to maintain
order and stability and all the while
we'll make the problem worse to feed our
industrial war machine and quietly
siphon off
all the water we need then you've got
individual billionaires like bill gates
who has finally gotten some recognition
as the terrible person he is for trying
to prevent free vaccine distribution
in order to make even more money the
gates family owns nearly 270
000 acres of land most of it
agricultural
if i were a betting man i would assume
that bill's got some nefarious intent
with the water rights on that land
then of course we've also commodified
water and you can now speculate on water
futures on the stock
market but we can modify everything so
this should come as no surprise
though it does seem deeply dystopian to
have wealthy people betting on drought
severity while their fellow human beings
suffer
if you put that in a movie script the
producers would say it's too on the nose
but this is the reality of the state of
water precarity around the world
reserves are drying up key sources of
fresh water are quickly becoming
flashpoints for conflict
and imperialist nations like the us are
gearing up to fight their next
generation of wars over water
it's a shame to say that we really
shouldn't have expected any different
the only goal of the imperial core and
capitalist powers of the world is
and always has been the maintenance of
global domination and the exploitation
of the developing world for their
resources
water is no different it's a resource
that everyone needs
and that makes it incredibly valuable
the water wars are coming
they won't be advertised as such but
watch where imperialist militaries end
up
it's only a matter of time
[Music]
if you'd like to learn more about what
the world could look like as we approach
day zero
i highly recommend you check out world
without water on curiosity
stream it's a sobering look at the state
of water scarcity around the world
but it does offer a ray of hope
curiosity stream is an established
streaming platform with a solid track
record of caring about great educational
content and the financial security of
those who produce it
they've got thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
as you probably know youtube doesn't
treat its creators very well
that's why some of my youtuber friends
and i teamed up to build nebula
so we don't have to worry about
demonetization as educational creators
ourselves
we love curiosity stream so we've worked
out a deal where if you sign up for
curiosity stream at the link below
you'll also get access to nebula 100
free that's less than 15 bucks a year
for both curiosity stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since most of us are still
waiting for the vaccine
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiosity stream
or check out nebula's original content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism
you can also watch all my videos as they
were intended ad free
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula
when you sign up using the link below it
really does help support my channel and
educational creators all across youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week